we were the covered we notion of area
between eh
each other and die xaxis using the definite
in euro week after korn good and extended
is to think what die area between cares
seletti week after the region of mexico
c-tek sequels be between my goals en van
wax in mycology works so we beer
this area
wright
about here so based on what you're the
know about them girls
how you actually try to calculate is
what natural think you might as well and
fire ethics who in a role of a baby
and  fmx
that ex
that we gimme the entire area
below and forex
and barbie xaxis and dinosaur pulls up
from that this area
red over here
what is culture that the devil in euro van
eib
jeee and x dx wel that we just finished with the
regional and red eye  care about a we just
out with this area save for here and
there in that would be the case and we
know for my integration drapery week
and rewrite the session 1 euro from eib
and right here
and forex
mind is 3 x
minus 4 x
dx and  now make up claims centuries becomes
builder bit more into fashion for this
is me go to this video met take over role
from ebi for fmx is greater than she
walks like this info for 4
dit is always going to be the case
de the area between the curse
is just to provide in a role for that
extra volume times bath of baby nffs
industry works
finally i think i like okay what gets
some butter them more about the xaxis
drill body case one fmx is the body xaxis
angie wax is below the access so for
sample lets eat we were to think by
the sinner fullness here what are this is
the pointee
and that sexy cosi this is x eagles die
savior here so whatever i want you
calculate
this area but i'm sharing in reason for
here you must be  thousand this
actually work well i think about now
what the integral link about what the
integral
van see today
and forex
die x-ray process what we represent
this area
wright over here and wat we the integral
van
see today jeee and werk die extra push it
will you might say it is this area
savior here for member
about this interval jacks is below the
xaxis
zo this would give you a negative wel
preview had stolen larry yes with that
lasted i so blue area which has a
dead-end and subtract so negative  area
and so then you'll get up at the entire
kasbergen want this just amounted to
this is i want you die in a role of
see today
and forex
forex
meines jackson and
minus relax
emeka create exactly dr
and then i have a jacks
as long  the game of this about this interval of
when a effect was a barbie
exact e-synergy wedges below the access
how you still world around you so a
b or stab another scenario i read the
scenario when they're boot below the
access
letter i  wanna go from
action cabbage mushroom fusions and vd loo
letter with marx and zo seven gmail acc
from california or letters after dinner
die and min ago from
autonomic scaldis bucket bucket scaldis
and ride over here and is killing and
driver here so eye care but  is this area
die er 20 in below and for showing that
were looking it in a role heavy fs
greater than gigolo en and greater than
she was stil en mounted is wat nabhi en
point be emmen en
wel gut stink barolo bed
ik word we wel je  know that a lot of
him te and
[ __ ] that action you
fmx
meines
meines jacks
wiardi nova but integral barbies this is
just jubi culture that role of m2
and fmx
that is ex mind that intro of him and jack
jacks nothing for each of these wrapper
are so so yellow and guide over here
there i become
this we negative of this area
so that we the g19 value here but who me
with your deeds that absolutely it would be
this area where affair
well what widgets those intuitive things
with the nine tips are here  lived in
a grill or these jacks of this blue in
copy what we give this the negative
of this entire my hours i'm
negative and bold and so
this part rider here so in time
recruiting the snow sign with glass
which gives this entire area the  entire
er so what chicer we a break de value
kloetinge 1995
but for that there every week airboat
ride over here that there a week earlier
at regionally wie walter subtract thus
yellow area well this ride over here so
yellow integral of the in the devil of
mtf  effect directly i tell you that is
a negative mr sophie where the blue
area and san de 1995 invasive and and this
is can provide negative of the yellow
area you that once again to the area de
wie tinkebell
so in every case with a the branching
true full true effects great en jacks
the area between the map is correct the
definition 1 euro about die and er vol or
effect mymessage x dx